I hear the secrets that you keep.
When you're talking in your sleep.
All your dreams that you keep inside…
You're telling me the secrets that you just
can't hide.
Hey there, sleepers.
Somniloquy, is the name given to the sleep
abnormality of talking in your sleep.
For some unknown reason, some people will
snooze comfortably and quietly, whereas others
will speak gibberish, words, sentences, or
entire speeches whilst sawing their logs.
Understanding somniloquy involves understanding
a bit about sleep first.
As you fall asleep, your brain's reticular
activating system (RAS) hands control over
to the ventrolateral preoptic nucleus (VLPO)
for sleepytime.
During that transition is when you twitch,
btw -- we did a whole video on that!
Once asleep, the brain goes through a predictable
set of four stages (one of those is famous
Rapid Eye Movement, or REM sleep, where dreaming
happens).
During sleep, your brain squirts out two paralyzing
chemicals glycine and GABA.
These keep your vocal chords (and mouth, body
muscles and such) paralyzed.
Okay, so… scientists don't have any idea
why some people talk in their sleep.
Sleep talking can occur at any time during
REM or non-REM sleep; which means it's not
necessarily when we voice a dream, it can
be anytime!
Scientists think sometimes, people might slip
through their own paralyzing net of glycine
and GABA and end up voicing what's happening
inside their head; called a "motor breakthrough."
Or maybe it's because of "transitory arousal,"
which is when we switch between sleep stages.
It's related to sleepwalking and night terrors
and about half of all children and five percent
of adults will talk in their sleep; and it's
more common among men than women -- though
sleep researchers don't know why.
Sometimes sleep talking is just a few words,
sometimes it's 30 seconds or more and it's
hardly ever sensical.
Sometimes sleep talkers are sweet, sometimes
they're explicit, sometimes they whisper,
sometimes they shout; and that's where it
can turn into a problem for those sharing
a bedroom with others.
A study of over 2000 schoolchildren published
in the journal Brain and Development found
only 10 percent of children will sleep talk
every night, but 50 percent will do so once
a year.
According to another study in Pediatrics,
by age 13 most childhood sleep abnormalities
declined, but not somniloquy!
The problem with most sleep studies is we
don't remember talking in our sleep; because
we're asleep!
And, even when sharing a bed, instances are
so brief the other sleeping person commonly
misses it too, unless there's persistent conversation
-- which is possible.
Look up Sleep Talkin' Man for some entertaining
sleep talking.
So funny.
Other than the possibility of waking your
bedfellow, sleep talking isn't generally harmful.
Though, when people frequently experience
somniloquy after age 25, the National Sleep
Foundation recommends seeking professional
help.
Somniloquy is not connected to insanity, as
portrayed in films and stories, simply stress.
The National Sleep Foundation says adult somniloquy
can be brought on by stress, fever, sleep
deprivation, alcohol or drugs, or something
more serious, like depression.
Psychology Today advises partners to invest
in a fan, white noise machine, or good earplugs,
if it's causing sleep interruption, but rest-assured
that you'll rest-assured soon.
Often the behavior is short-lived, either
during a period of waking high stress, poor
sleep, or just kids being kids.
Practicing healthy sleep behaviors -- limiting
caffeine and screens, and keeping a regular
bed and wake time -- all decrease instances
of sleep talking in adults.
Oh, and if you ARE worried about spilling
your secrets, courts have ruled talking in
your sleep is inadmissible as evidence, as
it's not the product of a conscious mind,
so sleep soundly, criminal friends.
Have you ever experienced somniloquy?
Either as the talker or the woken up partner?
Tell me in the comments and be sure you sub.
And for more on sleep check out this GREAT
video from a handsome devil about how sleeping
pills don't actually help you sleep.
Thanks!